thank you okay
here are the uh questions
okay what do you think is the main
culprit driving inflation do you think
the biden administration is equipped to
solve it
stomp the band there i guess on the
first one you get dinner at pepe's
uh yeah what do you think is the main
culprit
well first of all obviously too much
money we trillions of dollars okay that
means that you can't deny that party and
and suddenly the all of this
supply chain stops and at the same time
everyone wants to buy that's
extraordinary it's unprecedented it's
staggering it gives you 30-year
inflation highs but then on top of that
the russians invade ukraine and china
locking down and china locking down
what's what's up with that and we forgot
to mention covet that's why they're
locking down and that drove a lot of
this the spending
uh and the pent up demand well we didn't
have to handle covert that way
we well we didn't handle it the way
china did does no i
[ __ ] hope not
i mean
i mean that is what is going on in china
what i mean jane you were an ambassador
to china and the first woman on the moon
what
uh
yeah
uh what is going on
people don't know i mean
shanghai is a city of 25 million people
where you are locked in your apartment i
mean they often kill your pets
uh
it's you
i've never seen anything like this and i
don't know i don't know why they think
it could possibly work you can't control
a virus
completely like this you just can't
i don't think it is working i think it's
working to gin up the public against the
government you think it's working yes
the problem is that their draconian
lockdowns worked really well when the
disease was not so transmissible and now
it's much more transmissible and their
vaccines don't work and they refuse to
license american and european vaccines
we have them and we should expect less
virulent
you know i mean bill gates did you read
his quote this week who just got kovit
yeah he just got covered um and he said
well we didn't realize it first
that it was mostly disease of the
elderly a relatively low fatality rate
and more like the flu oh you mean the
things a lot of people were saying at
the beginning and they were called crazy
things that would have been taken off of
twitter at the time by the way right no
question there you go with twitter yeah
damn we should put that into the
regulation
[Applause]
uh
do you think lawmakers are doing enough
to remedy the baby formula shortage by
launching an oversight investigation
really into baby formula is it is it a
conspiracy to deny baby formula i don't
know what it was i mean oversight of
baby for no it's just this kind of stuff
right it's not a conspiracy it's just
well it's a lot of concentration of
power in a few companies and it's a
supply chain what would you do about
that uh
try to get apparently all of the major
companies okay
it's not 20 companies i think it's three
or four and they're trying to welcome
the show business yeah
that's right that's a different problem
but i mean it's the same thing
i mean there's very often not 20
companies very often only two or three
companies selling airlines you know i
mean
if you're most routes there's sometimes
it's only one carrier
this was the worst crisis of our
lifetimes what baby no
and the trillions of dollars that were
spent
not the worst crisis of my life for sure
no
and i mean you think that's not going to
lead to massive dislocation when
suddenly people didn't have money they
couldn't work suddenly everyone's
spending it at the same time yeah you're
going to have problems are you saying
that's where the baby formula problem is
coming i think it's a big part of it
absolutely
and yet during coven people did not make
babies they thought oh locked inside
they're going to make lots of babies
like during a blackout no it was more
like i'm sick of you
you're the last person
i'm sorry but that's what happened
okay
early this week earlier this week
biden used the phrase ultra magga
multiple times in his speech about
inflation do you think this is an
effective messaging strategy ultra maga
yeah as a he was saying it
as a pejorative right he was saying the
ultra magga but manga means make america
great again it it i could see how that
wouldn't be a great
i thought it was a premium brand you
know like like gas
at four bucks and fifty cents a gallon
ultra mag that's gonna work better right
[Applause]
i don't think it works very well
it sounds like a condom
ultra maggot sounds like a condom it
does
it's larger around works for trouble
yeah but don't you think
putin should get a big red hat that says
uh merga make russia great again isn't
that what he's trying to do in some
misguided way trump
putin
putin yes of course well every country
wants to make their country great well i
mean he's making it uh less great right
now i mean trump that's not even trump's
original phrase make america great again
clinton used it and reagan used it you
know it's it's an it's an obvious i like
that it's make america great again again
right
it's turtles all the way down they'll do
that without irony absolutely
yeah all right thank you very much thank
you folks
you